oh yes I'm a fan of pineapple pizza  yes that's my jam no pizzas a peek sup  man pineapple sapphire now absolutely  not  pineapple on pizza yes sweet and salty  no it's just wrong like stop Pizza is  not is not to the plate you put on my  wife likes yes I have a number of  arguments of people going coast you'd  say I even whales cross us  oh yes I like mine Apple but it does not  belong my husband Hawaiian I'm into it  totally for me 100% I love it yes I hate  that I like spam upon anything spam is  delicious pineapples do not belong on  pizza  the Chicago people put a pineapple on a  pizza they'll cut your pineapple oh yes  that is a hard yeah I'm a big fan I  would add to that pineapple belongs in  salsa  [Music]